quien tiene más en juego en este debate
de este viernes
Muy buenas tardes un gusto poder hablar
con ustedes de fans México trae una vez
más
este debate de hoy es un debate
absolutamente fundamental en la
principal cadena de televisión de Brasil
que es la red globo va a ser en la noche
de hoy y decenas de millones de personas
van a estar en la audiencia de este
debate Creo yo que es la última
oportunidad para que el presidente del
mandatario en converte Javier bolsonaro
intenta cambiar el escenario el panorama
porque todas las encuestas apuntan para
la victoria por más o menos cinco o seis
puntos de Luis en absolula da Silva en
el próximo domingo sin embargo en la
primera vuelta también las encuestas
apuntaban para una ventaja una ventaja
muy larga de Lula Pero eso no Se
confirmó Tal vez eso sea resultado de la
distensión
o la gente que no comparece a las
sesiones para votar en la primera vuelta
fueron más de 30 millones de brasileños
y brasileñas que no estuvieron en sus
sesiones para votar esto puede ser un
problema para entonces la elección está
más o menos direccionada para la
victoria de Lula pero vamos a tener la
certeza la certidumbre efectivamente
cuando empezar el conteo de todas las
sesiones hoy yo apostaría que Lula tiene
una posibilidad
de 70 a 80% de Victoria en el próximo
domingo efectivamente Esa primera vuelta
evidenció que la diferencia entre
evolucionario y Lula no es tanta cómo
reaccionó cada candidato a esos
resultados del 12 de octubre para buscar
ahora la victoria en esta segunda vuelta
Lula intentó ampliar su ya amplia su
amplio frente de apoyadores de diversos
partidos incluso de antiguos
aniversarios
de Centro derecha de Centro
tal vez la más importante el más
importante apoyo a Lula es de el ex
presidente Fernando Enrique Cardozo
nosotros podemos acordarnos que Cardozo
y Lula pelearon usted con sus
respectivos partidos durante más o menos
20 años en Brasil pero ahora están están
juntos por intentar a derrotar a
bolsonaro que comprenden como además que
un taller exista una amenaza a la
democracia brasileña y a la democracia
de toda la América Latina y bolsa
realmente intentó trabajar con sus
apoyadores
fidelizar aún más sus soldados porque
son verdaderos soldados y que intentan
producir esta
montada Este cambio de escenario por
sonaron no logró hablar para más gente
que no los mismos que ya habían votado
por él en la primera vuelta entonces
este Este es un problema muy complicado
para bolsonar aunque tenga intentado no
logró
apasionar más gente apasionar más
electores para su nombre y para su
candidatura teniendo en cuenta que se
espera que en la segunda vuelta haya
menos votantes En qué tipo de lectores
cree usted que está la clave para
decidir esta votación
yo creo que los pobres la gente pobre la
gente que vive
principalmente en la región noreste de
Brasil en las pequeñas ciudades
gente que vive en las periferias de las
grandes metrópolis esta gente es
fundamental principalmente para Lula si
los muy pobres no van a votar Luna va a
tener problemas porque ahí la diferencia
la distancia entre
él y bolsonaro se va a
se va a tornar mucho más mucho más
chiquita